depending on which way you measured it
right I'm your diagrams I expect with
all look quite different in fact just as
ice King's people's numbers I don't
think I saw a single set of numbers that
were all the same now quick quick
question for you not rhetorical why all
the numbers different yeah okay very
good so if you're looking at that corner
right and I asked a few Jewishness as
you started walking you're like oh I
think it's about over there but then as
you've got there you're like okay hi
children environment the corner I was
actually quite far away right so as a
consequence if of course you don't need
to draw this but because you start
somewhere and then what you measure is
actually this distance run the true
diagonal then clearly you're going to
have a different measure okay what else
what other kinds of things could account
for the differences that you observe any
takers yeah we okay very good so we've
kind of got this perfect world where
it's like yes of course I can walk in a
straight line whereas as soon as pretty
much you've taken your eye off where
you're going you kind of do this and I
oh no I'm over here and then you kind of
get there eventually yeah all that adds
distance doesn't it right the more wavy
your line is going longer than a Whoopi
I can think of at least one other
there's probably more well at least one
other major thing that would cause some
differences anyone yeah
it's the trundle wheels for now let's
actually talk about this trend of wheel
for a second nearly on if you've got
another different reason I will come
back to because I want a lot some more
um we know how this works right so you
push it on and it clicks so that
actually means something really
important for us because when we look at
error in measurement one of the ways you
could know is to look at whatever scale
is on there right but what were you
measuring you know one was special
incentives were they you're measuring
per click so what does that mean the
limit of reading as you used it of this
is the limit of really is careful the
limit of reading is 1 meter that's the
heinous the greatest possible error is
half meter up half a million down that's
the United shows okay so it's going to
add things in um eliana did you have
something else you wanted to okay yeah
not only did you maybe end at the spot
you didn't mean to you can start and it
completely a different point I thought
it's quite amusing actually it'd be
really boring I suppose whoever walks at
exactly a straight line but everyone was
all over the place ok now I'm going to
add one more thing in which was up oh
yeah sorry we go yeah so like in the
ground yeah okay see you like it the
reason I did this is cuz there was like
a pothole there okay yes all these kinds
of things account for deviations in the
fun so I say okay what do you mean by i
supped well
with your eyes where you want em yeah so
we discussed this before yeah use your
eyes much better than he knows uh we've
discussed this before we went out right
in that we theory would like a
measurement that's exactly 90 degrees
off but of course I don't think most of
us had anything even run across the back
right so we did our best we got some
measurements that were still to my
ballpark but still there were many
differences in those yeah last one yes
as in you repeat this measure twice yeah
that's promising that's what is a
rewarder of image and if you get the
same thing that's confirmation Laura
join Adam yeah
started at halfway very good so you guys
see I don't know how many of you pay
attention the fact that it says start
today right it's like I thought either
you never noticed that it was there or
you notice me like yeah I'm real super
accurate and that lasted about 20
seconds and then you're like air
afterwards you sort of don't really mind
it okay and these are going to if you
start from up fee are you get your first
click before meters actually allows does
that make sense okay so here's what I
want you to do now I want you to stand
maybe five or ten minutes we're working
with whoever was in your heart to do
this we need to draw the diagrams there
we need to draw the dyers all we've got
is the numbers right now so I want you
to pay particular attention when you
have your numbers that obviously are not
these exact numbers right but which
direction to your members go in where
did you actually place that measurement
and therefore what kind of a diagram are
you going to create I'll give you a few
miss to do that do you have a shot and
if you feel like we do that really quick
feel free to try and work out the area
and perimeter